In this lecture, we'll
introduce linear optimization
and apply it to airline
revenue management.
Air transportation became a
reality in the United States
in the 20th century.
From 1938 to 1978, the
Civil Aeronautics Board
set fares, routes, and
schedules for all interstate air
transport.
Most airlines were very
positive on this system,
as it guaranteed their profits.
However, this system led to
higher costs for a traveling
public as well as to
various inefficiencies.
For example, applications
for new routes and fares
were often delayed or dismissed.
In response to these
inefficiencies,
the administration
of President Carter
passed the Airline
Deregulation Act in 1978.
The act encouraged
more competition.
As a result, 52
new airlines were
formed between 1980 and 2000.
Also, new air routes appeared.
Correspondingly,
it saved passengers
an estimated $10.3 billion
each year in travel time.
Lower fares was another outcome.
Ticket prices are now 40%
lower than they were in 1978.
This led to more passengers.
The number of air passengers
increased from over 200 million
in 1974 to over 720
million in 2010.
More competition
led to lower fares,
as we discussed, while
meeting operating costs.
This further led to heavy
losses by air carriers.
Nine major carriers and more
than a hundred smaller airlines
went bankrupt between
1978 and 2002.
So it is natural to ask
how did airlines compete?
In their attempt
to sell more seats,
airlines started to
offer deep discounts.
For example, on
January 17, 1985,
American Airlines launched
its Ultimate Super Saver fares
to compete with PeopleExpress.
The key strategy involved
selling enough seats
to cover fixed operating
costs while selling remaining
seats at higher rates
to maximize revenues.
This led to the science
of revenue management
that we'll study
in this lecture.
The key question in
revenue management
is how many seats
to sell on discount.
The key consideration
is that passengers
have different valuations.
For example, business
people value flexibility,
whereas people seeking a
vacation value good deals.
So if we sell too
many discounted seats,
then there would
not be enough seats
for high-paying passengers.
At the same time, if we sell
too few discounted seats,
then we will have empty seats,
which lead to lost revenue.
So the key question is
how airlines like American
can allocate their seats
among customers in order
to maximize their revenue.